[Music]
have you ever wanted to be
a hulk have you ever wanted to be a
black panther everybody wants to be a
superhero
and that's what realm of champions is
all about it's about
making marvel yours marvel realm of
champions
is a multiplayer you play with your
friends in real time
if you're a marvel fan and you've always
wanted to
create your own marvel character put
your own twist
on it i think you'll want this game
[Music]
the story of realm of champions started
being told like for real in
contest of champions marvel contest of
champions is the first marvel game we
made
uh six years ago and i think gabe always
had
plans for what he was going to do with
the maestro
the maestro is this really evil version
of the hulk
and he wants to become a god essentially
we had reached the end of one storyline
in contest of champions
and it grew into something so expansive
we felt like we needed to make a whole
new game to tell that story
battle world is our entry point into the
game
battle world is a planet that is
composed of a bunch of different
realities that have been brought
together
forcibly by the maestro there's been
many versions of it you know of course
the the original one was from the
original secret wars from 1985.
later we had secret wars 2015 was you
know
it plays with that with the same concept
but it's in a much more
complex way there's 80 plus years of
marvel history
to to pull from for this stuff so where
do you take from
what do you leave for later we really
wanted the world itself to capture the
essence of the characters for example
one of the first ones i worked on was
the house of iron
and we took the idea of tony stark
wanting to protect everyone and build a
suit of armor around the world
so we started with an armored wall and a
shield
and buildings that look like his armor
so the first thing that you're going to
get introduced to is this big
mystery the maestro the god emperor of
better world
the all-powerful you know green emperor
get murdered
you need to find out who killed the
maestro because as evil as he was
he was keeping a lot of things in check
and making sure that
lots of people didn't die but then we
focus into
the center with the eighth houses that
we're going to start the game with the
major houses the house of iron is a
technological utopia
the spider guild in this world they are
traffickers of information
the of hearts they're barbarian hulks oh
the vishanti
uh they are basically a mystic
university that brings together
all the different mystic traditions from
the multiverse
the people of wakanda got exiled so they
have to rebuild the country of wakanda
from scratch the garrison is the moral
guidance of this world
pyramid x its apocalypse kingdom
or the first of our ex-houses so the
asgardian republic
they are our version of the nine realms
first thing you you see
is that start prime proposes that all
the houses
come together and not fight and not go
to war so this is the first stage of
the story this is called the iron age i
don't know about you
but if fighting a secret war will
prevent an open one to a time game
visual customization has always been at
the core of the game
not only are you becoming more powerful
just by leveling up your character but
you're also earning
rare gear with different enhancements on
it
the better your gear the more able
you'll be to compete in
the competitive arena conquest game mode
which will earn you more reputation
with that house that you're trying to
infiltrate and as that
reputation increases again more story
will come to you
from a visual development standpoint
it's been really cool
i sort of get a peek at all of the
concept art that comes in
for these weapons and their their
variants and
the the gear and all the variants and
stuff that's coming down down the line
yeah just like the worlds there's so
much marvel influence
in the gear even for the smallest piece
of gear it would start
with talking to gabe about the narrative
and how it fits into the narrative and
that would inspire the visuals
you want as much variety in the sets as
possible but you also have to be able to
combine them together in a way that
makes sense
for sorcerer supreme we've merged her
design sense with
scarlet witch and you can combine that
with
her voodoo design and her ancient
one-inspired design
so so many different looks but you can
combine them together in a crazy way
there's three sort of core roles to the
game tank characters are really going to
be setting the formation of your team
they're going to be on the front line
engaging
and pulling attention away from weaker
characters like the attack and the
support characters
attack characters are going to hang back
and either jump in and deal sort of
shots of damage
or stay back and and deal damage
consistently from afar
and then support characters also hang
back but their main focus is to debuff
their enemies or buff their allies to
really enhance the abilities of those
other two classes
having those three roles is important to
creating balanced
teams like our vision
has really come together the story the
visuals
and everything works so well together
what you see now in the game
is is just a tiny fraction of what we
have planned there's so much
so many stories that we want to tell
it's really only the beginning and you
can expect
some new story content new game modes
coming soon so
look forward to it
you